Oh Oh thirsty hey I'm Terry Crews and
I'm about to read some thirst tweets
let's get this all our tweets Terry
Crews you are one sexy [ __ ]
hashtag big hashtag chocolate man ha ha
that's true
I'm chocolate a little almond so I'm
nuts too so it's okay
I want to lather up Terry Crews lay him
down and slide my body all over his
Ripple what you know what I don't want
to do that to myself too
Terry Crews is so sexy too bad he's
married you know the fact that I am Mary
is the only thing to make you sexy
because I'm single but nobody feeling
for me nobody does anyone else think
Terry Crews would be great in bed
oh boy y'all in love with that fantasy
I'm trying to tell you ask my wife she's
over it Terry Crews to take his shirt
off anytime he wants that's fine with me
you know what I do I do I take my shirt
off literally if it's a little bit too
hot it's gone so it's no problem you
know take me taking my shirt off is
family entertainment Christmas list
beanbag chair sex appeal
sexy Terry Crews calendar Terry Crews
meaty hand equals Drake
you know this head is me I'm trying to
say you look at it like that's irking
okay look at how I just kind of
you can just put a finger in between
each way that's look one ear at a time
when you like that hey Terry Crews this
might be a bit forward but may I please
lick your biceps like a mom cleaning up
a melting ice cream okay first of all
this is probably the best piece of
fiction I've ever read it is drama here
there's a whole story there's people
involved this is a movie this is what
I'm gonna turn this tweet into a film
idea Terry Crews got that let me lick
whipped cream off your body tight body
well you just copying the do boom before
this is plagiarism plagiarism so I
already got the movie with the licking
biceps come on can we be a little more
inventive with your thirst Terry Crews
and all these muscles I bet he is the
tea in bed again it's the fantasy ah it
ain't the tea it's not the tea I just
got I'm breaking the myth I'm a
mythbuster right now me and the boys
talking about Terry Crews and my buddy
jingles I let him kiss me on the cheek
and hold his pocket
oh man you and the guys you know I guess
you know what I still wanna rub my ass
Oh Terry Crews you know he said that
like he's been saying this so long like
he's been saying this for years look you
still wanna do that yeah yeah I still
want to rub my ass on Terry Crews
how would you tweet that hey this is
Terry Crews that I have enjoyed reading
these thirsty tweets thank you for your
thirst I appreciate it I hope you're not
thirsty anymore
[Laughter]
[Music]